I returned to that question we had about
GPT and the language models and I think
about this
quite a lot which is when uh the model
and we know what is trained on we know
the parameters
when all the different hacks that are
involved in the training process and the
fine-tuning process
and the final results well there's GPT
five six or seven will result in
hundreds of millions of people falling
deeply in love
with that language model and to be able
to have conversations
that are very much like the
conversations we have with somebody
we're deeply in love with and not only
that the model
will say that is deeply in love with us
and who are we to say it is not
I think there's a
it's the same imperative that you
described in the scientific mind
that wants to throw away the subjective
that same imperative wants to throw away
the feelings that AI might have
and I'm very careful
to not ignore when an AI system says
it's lonely
it's afraid it doesn't want to die it
misses you right it loves you I am I'm
with you I would also say
that you could try to you could for
instance say that
um the origin of that
is the you know romantic novels that
overfed to it for instance yes however
you could also then you can retort but
what if my what I consider my subjective
unique feelings are also novels
reparations of the novels I have read
because I have learned or movies I have
seen yeah because that's the purpose of
movies kind of to teach us how to
express ourselves how to feel maybe even
one could argue that some people have
argued that
I agree that this is
um
there is no obvious answer to this but
see that's exactly my point that is an
example of something which is
paradoxical
for which there is no answer and that's
where the subjective has a has an
important role for someone
uh that type of interaction
would be would be helpful would be
consoling would would feel would you
know make them happy or sad or whatever
you know what kind of strike the nerve
for some it won't
and I agree with you that
in principle there is no one to to judge
this this is this is where subjective is
Paramount but remember
um a lot of this has been anticipated
by artists the great movie her there you
have this guy who is this lonely
he kind of writes letters some romantic
letters yeah for other people but he
isn't he doesn't have a partner he's
lonely and then he gets this sort of a
kind of enhanced version of Siri with
the voice
of Scarlett Johansson which is very sexy
boys you know obviously she's a great
actress so
and then at first it looks like a
fantastic arrangement
he he confides in her he she she she
tells him things he is she makes him
happy and so on until he finds out that
she has a relationship quote unquote if
you can call it that with 10 000 other
people not two others not three others
yeah like 10 000 because it's a it has a
Computing capability so yes definitely
oh it certainly makes sense it's a good
explanation and the guy is heartbroken
yeah but see so see here's my analysis
of this okay it's like a couch a couch a
therapist okay
the guy did not have the courage to go
out in the in the real world and to meet
a woman and to you know get a girlfriend
and so on it's true no fault of his own
perhaps because you know he may have had
some experiences which made him
withdrawn and closed and so on and a lot
of us are like this you know I had
periods like that myself definitely I
can sympathize and relate
however
part of the joy of having this Theory
like
um relationship
for him one could say was the absence of
that fear that she would abandon him
which prevented him from
initiating a relationship with a human
being
and yet it turns out that he could be
betrayed quote unquote that she could be
unfaithful to him quote unquote anyway
so then that means that it did not
resolve the underlying fear having that
relationship so in other words that
human element of the relationship
still found its way into this seemingly
sterilized protected protected
partnership so the human being rears its
head anyway and I think the lesson there
is that the system in the movie Her
actually gave him a lesson that even AI
could betray you even if I can leave you
even AI can be uh unfaithful to you and
I would argue that the next AI he meets
will be one he actually falls in deep
love with because he knows the
possibility of betrayal is there the
possibility of death is there the
possibility of infidelity is there
because we need that possibility to
truly feel core or he would turn off his
Siri program and finally and get out of
his house go to a local bar and strike a
conversation with a human being
although you might say by then some of
those might be Androids
and we don't even have a good chance to
know the difference and of course or the
other and that was predicted by another
great movie yeah right uh so the Blade
Runner Blade Runner how interesting that
artists
could see that so long ago you know of
course Blade Runner was based on a novel
by Philip K dick though Android's Dream
of Electric Sheep
that guy was a genius you know it's
somehow the artists have their eyes open
is it also a large language model that
they're using for that
an even larger one or even larger I I
hesitate to dismiss the magic
in large language models I uh a lot of
the work I've done is in robotics in the
robotics Community generally doesn't
notice the magic
of feeling
when I I work I've been working a lot
with quadrupeds recently legged robots
with four legs and
the feelings I feel when I see
uh you know I'm programming the thing
but when the thing is excited to see me
or shows with his physical movement that
it's excited to see me
I cannot dismiss the feeling I feel is
not somehow fundamental to what it means
to program robots and I don't want to
dismiss that and please don't please
don't the robotics Community often does
engender robots they really try to work
hard to not anthropomorphize the robots
which is good for technical development
of of how to do control how to do
perception but when the final thing is
alive
and moving and it does whatever like uh
I've been doing a lot of butt wiggling
it can wiggle his body can turn around
and look up yeah excited that's not just
I know how it's programmed but the
feeling I feel that's something that's I
don't know what that is I agree with you
I I hear I hear you when you speak about
it yeah you speak with passion yeah and
that's to me that is proof that it is
magical you see uh so don't I would say
don't dismiss that don't discard that on
the contrary I think magic is everywhere
you know so I used to be okay kind of
confession okay
you already get confessed to quite a few
addictions yeah I'm kind of uh yes I'm
kind of worried recover recovering for
many but you know I
in old days I was
more on the side of everything is
computational or everything can be
explained by science and whatever you
know like
I would dismiss and disregard you know
the intuitive or imaginative things so
then I had a flip that suddenly I
started feeling it and started seeing it
and so on but so then the pendulums had
swung in the opposite direction then I
was
arguing uh um
that you know somehow that was real that
imagination was intuitive imaginative
was real and discounting
what you just described
and I would argue with people saying no
no this you know this are not real this
is all you know imitation game and so on
but you see that
what's new now the new adword okay is
the the 2.0 or 3.0 yeah he's the one who
is seeking balance who is not who is
because suddenly become aware that no
matter which one-sided lopsided point of
view you take you're limiting yourself
so whereas even a couple of years ago
you know if you just told you told me
what you just described I would be like
you know being polite I would just I
wouldn't contradict you since you're the
host anyway right there's not a lot so
but I will be like but I wouldn't say
anything
but suddenly I find this
moving I find it move I honestly I'm not
being facetious I find it moving and I
almost feel like I can see it through
your eyes because the way you describe
so vividly and you're passionate about
it and this is what's real so ultimately
love is not
is neither in large language models nor
in something mystical it's exactly in
this moments of passion and I would I
would
I would even go as far as saying that in
this moment when you're describing it it
there was a connection of sorts so that
I could feel your passion for it and in
this moment something else comes up
Which is far beyond any
any theories that we can come up with
and that's what we for now exactly so on
one side there is this impulse of
finding this Theory a theory and then
there is another impulse to escape from
what has already been known so one in
other words like in my basic example is
one impulse to say everything is a real
number square root of negative one
doesn't exist but another impulse is I'm
going to be this naughty child who is
not afraid to be an idiot and I will say
square root of negative 15 is real
and both are essential
when it's done with conviction when it's
done with passion when it's not like you
know you know
um gratuitous or when it's not it
doesn't come from self-limit
self-limiting but comes from this sense
of this is how I am this is how I feel
it is real that's where the progress is
that's where creativity is and that's
where I would even say aerial connection
is because the strive to me that we I
observed today in our society and the
society level at the level of humans and
so on it comes from not seeing the other
person actually and being caught up in a
very specific conceptual bubble you see
and the way out of it is not to refine
the bubble but just break out of it a
good guide out of the bubble is a
childlike passion whatever discovering
that and following it Goosebumps yeah
following the Goosebumps yeah to to the
to the you know not the rigor of science
but uh the magic of Goosebumps and then
if you're interested try to find the
confirmation of those goof bumps in
science or whatever you know you know uh
you find interesting and most of the
time you'll fail and most time you fail
which we also love because then it sets
us up for that moment of bliss when we
succeed right exactly